last night incumbent Republican Florida
Senator Marco Rubio was brutally crushed
in a disastrous debate for him by
Challenger democratic congresswoman Val
demings I have not seen a debate like
this in a long time and we've covered
now close to a dozen different 2022
debates Live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook as we tend to do
I have not seen such a one-sided debate
until last night's debate where Val
demings just crushed Rubio he looked
despondent at certain points I also will
mention Rubio seemed not only like he
didn't want to be there but sort of like
he didn't think he needed to be there
his his attitude the entire debate was
that Val demings is sort of beneath him
why does he have to waste his time as
the incumbent senator
debating this lowly other individual and
she really crushed him now before we
look at some clips I will mention
demings wasn't perfect she definitely
wasn't perfect there were a few moments
where she gave Rubio very good openings
for easy and effective rebuttals and you
heard from the crowd that they were
effective there were some moments that
just weren't perfect but she was really
really good demings came out a very very
hot after Rubio accused her of never
having passed any legislation let's just
jump jump right into these this is very
interesting he's been in Congress for
over half a decade she's never passed
the bill not PPP not anything not a
single Bill she's passed has ever become
law I'm proud of the fact we saved
millions of jobs I'm proud of the fact
we did it in a bipartisan way that's not
true I know the senator look and I'm
really disappointed in you a Marco Rubio
because adults I think there was a time
when you did not lie in order to win I
don't know what happened to you you know
that is not true my first term in this
in the United States house I passed
legislation to help Law Enforcement
Officers with mental health programs
your first term in the Senate you voted
to turn Medicare into basically to
abolish it and then turn it into an
underfunded voucher program and then you
gave the biggest tax break to The Riches
of the Rich and said you'd pay for it
because the Social Security and Medicare
now Not only was she very much prepared
for these attacks Val demings chose to
do something interesting during the
debate while Marco Rubio continued to
basically address the moderators
moderator Val demings regularly turned
to Marco Rubio and directly addressed
him now in our live chat there were some
people who said this is not a good
approach it's coming off as too
aggressive and confrontational Val
demings is trying to play from behind
here and we'll look at the polling in a
bit I actually think that this was
exactly right because when she would do
that when she would turn to Rubio Rubio
visibly shrank away he he shrank away
from the confrontation let's look at
more clips and these are these really
are good
um here's just enough these don't really
need necessarily introductions of course
the senator who has never run anything
at all but his mouth would know nothing
about helping people and being there for
people when they are in trouble no one
plant the pandemic but our response to
it is everything individuals were
hurting families were hurting businesses
were hurting we passed the cares act
which the senator supported there were
some problems in the cares act with the
paycheck protection program that you
love to take credit for some say it was
poorly written some say it didn't help
the people that it was supposed to
didn't save the jobs that it was
supposed to there was a way to fix the
problems in the PPP through the American
Rescue plan and help people that were in
trouble but you play a politics Senator
and you did not do that your number one
job is a United States Senator is to
protect the health safety and well-being
of the American people you've been at it
for 24 years
of course yeah she had a very good mix
of passion but also very specific claims
from Marco Rubio's legislative Pastor
lack thereof this came up again during
the topic of prescription drugs and it's
just hard to say anything other than
deming's was prepared and Rubio seemed
resentful of even having to be there he
talked about pharmaceuticals he voted
against legislation that would help
reduce the cost of prescription drugs
and help cap the cost of insulin
and Rubio again it it seemed that he was
unsure how to respond now one of the
other interesting things about Val
demings is they can't go after her with
one of the really popular slogans of
2022 which is your part of this defund
the police movement demings was a police
officer a police detective and a police
chief and her credentials as a supporter
of law enforcement while also supporting
reform make it very difficult to attack
her on those lines and when the topic of
gun violence came up
the difference
in not only knowledge but even
commitment to dealing with gun violence
was palpably different the majority of
people in our nation
want us to do just that how long will
you watch people being gunned down in
first grade fourth grade high school
college Church synagogue a grocery store
a movie theater a mall and a nightclub
Congressman do nothing yeah and that was
a critical moment of the debate in fact
where I think it sort of turned Rubio
seemed almost defeated after that point
his only real successes after that point
in the debate were when demings gave him
an opening by misstepping about his
legislative past and those are those are
certainly mistakes that she made
um on continuing on the issue of gun
violence it just was really not good for
Rubio's why are these people going out
there
this is the same argument I understand I
want to go to college one demings for 60
seconds
you know people who are
the families of
victims of gun violence just heard that
and they're asking themselves what in
the hell did he just say indeed
Senator you use the the Pulse Nightclub
shooting as your inspiration
to run again
for the senate in 2016. Parkland uh
pulse is in my district
and yet you've done nothing
nothing
to help address gun violence and get
dangerous weapons out of the hands of
dangerous people Florida after Parkland
after you made promises that you had no
intentions on keeping to the parents of
Parkland Florida passed legislation
raising the age
to have an assault weapon pass red flag
laws that we've seen 7 000 plus
instances where they've been used now
to our primary responsibility is the
safety of Floridians and Senator 24
years in elected office and you have not
yet risen to that occasion and they when
asked about it you say something that
makes no sense yeah and it didn't make
any sense Rubio was asked multiple times
you previously said you would support
changing the age requirement for buying
a rifle
and now you don't seem to why not and
Rubio just went in circles never
actually acknowledging yes I changed my
position and here's why I changed my
position and here's why
um one of the strangest moments was when
the topic of election Integrity you know
whatever they want to call they have all
these names that the name it's the name
you use already implies a particular
position but the topic of ballot drop
boxes came out and Rubio talked about
how dangerous they are
that's a method of voting that doesn't
Advantage one group or another there's
danger involved in drop boxes people
need to think about it okay imagine
someone decides oh there's a Dropbox I'm
just going to put some explosive in it
and blow it up and burn all those
ballots and now those votes don't count
at all right there is there's something
with elections there are two things that
are very important number one the count
has to be accurate the votes have to be
counted accurately but the other is
there has to be public confidence yeah
so Rubio's saying the reasons that
ballot drop boxes are bad are someone
might bomb the Dropbox okay I mean it
hasn't happened and I wouldn't
necessarily start giving people ideas
and he claims people don't have
confidence in the Dropbox as well the
first thing has never happened and he
probably shouldn't be encouraging people
to do it bombing a Dropbox the second
thing is the reason some people don't
have confidence in Dropbox is is because
people like Marco Rubio tell them that
they the dropboxes can't be trusted that
you shouldn't have confidence in them
it's a vicious circle
we need voting systems that people can
fight in and the reason people don't
confide in this one is because I told
them not to oh well stop telling them
not to confide in it and then we would
eliminate that problem
uh Rubio earlier in the debate said you
know on gun laws stricter gun laws don't
make a difference because the criminals
would find a way around it but then he's
saying well we got to get rid of the
drop boxes to avoid someone blowing one
up well wouldn't criminals just find a
different way to burn ballots if that's
what they were determined to do it
doesn't really make any sense one more
clip the topic of abortion came up and
there were a lot of Clips I could play
on this but in the interest of time
let's look at one in particular this is
really kind of emblematic of the dynamic
on this issue during yesterday's debate
so you talk about Lindsey Graham's bill
that's a four-month band okay that is
more lenient than every country in
Europe except for two
the extremist on abortion in this
campaign is congresswoman demings she
supports no restrictions no limitations
of any kind by the way he said about six
or seven times that Val Deming supports
no limitations she multiple times said I
support no limitations up until the
gestational age of viability which I I
don't I think it's between 21 and 26
weeks roughly some somewhere in there
but he just kept repeating that lie he
voted against the form she's against the
four-month man she voted against a
five-month ban she supports
taxpayer-funded abortion on demand for
any reason at any time up until the
moment of birth that's what she supports
that's the extreme position here I have
shown a willingness to work with people
to save unborn innocent human life she
opposes any limitation of any kind and
no one ever asks them about that guys
William Jennings
I said how gullible do you really think
Florida voters are well the people
voting for Rubio are very gullible so
she's actually on to something there
number one you have been clear that you
support no exceptions
even including rape and incest now as a
police detective who investigated cases
of rape and incest no Senator I don't
think it's okay for a ten-year-old girl
to be raped and have to carry the seed
of her rapist no I don't think it's okay
for you to make decisions for women and
girls as a senator I think those
decisions are made between the woman her
family her daughter and her faith and to
sit over or to stand over there and say
that I'd support don't support abortions
up to the time of birth it's just a lie
but to help protect the life of the
mother which you looked at that like it
was just well kind of a well that's kind
of a side issue
Senator you know that you have said you
don't support any exception so the
debate dramatically in deming's favor
the question is is it too little too
late because the polling is not
particularly good for Val deming's
latest uh Real Clear Politics average of
recent polling has Marco Rubio up 4.7
points just shy of Five Points that is a
big deficit to overcome in just two and
a half weeks or how long do we have left
until the election one two just under
three weeks it is a deficit to overcome
but let's hope that yesterday's debate
performance will help Val demings
overcome some of it one other thing it
always happens you know this this has
been going on for so long
when a woman like Val demings shows up
takes the aggressive approach
turns and looks at Rubio when she's
telling him that he's lying points to
Rubio
there are always reactions that oh she's
being too aggressive she's too assertive
etc etc and the same sort of demeanor
from male candidates is often seen as
powerful
commanding uh indicative of a control
over the issues and the circumstances
and there were indeed even people in my
chat yesterday saying oh demmings is
coming off too aggressive turning this
that the other thing I think she did I
genuinely think she did a great job she
did a fantastic job one of the best
debate performances so far not perfect
but very very close and let's see what
kind of ground if any Val demmings can
make up in the 20 or so days between now
and the election let me know your
thoughts your reaction to the debate you
can find me on Twitter at dpacman
right now many of us are asking
ourselves what's the best way to help
the people affected by the recent
hurricanes and the truth is giving them
cash is one of the best things you can
do because cash is so cost effective
when you give families cash you're also
empowering them to choose for themselves
how to best improve their situation and
I've talked before about our sponsor
give directly give directly is a
non-profit that just lets donors like
you send cash directly to families who
need it the most give directly is a
great organization I've been following
for years a lot of their focus is on
impoverished families in Africa but
right now give directly is also allowing
you to send cash directly to families
impacted by hurricanes Ian and Fiona
during Hurricane Ian more than two and a
half million people were ordered to
leave their homes expenses are rising
they need food shelter Transportation
hurricane Fiona hit Puerto Rico on
September 18th more than 12 000 people
displaced the island is still in a state
of emergency and people need help visit
give directly.org Pacman to learn more
and send money directly to someone who
needs it the link is down below